NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
こんにちは、UITのテオです。ユーザーインターフェースとテクノロジーを愛する開発者のためのポッドキャストのUIT INSIDE。今回もやっていきたいと思います。今回は佐野さんと玉田さんと一緒に2025年を振り返ってみたいです。よろしくお願い
佐野さん、今回なんと初めてこのポッドキャストにいらっしゃってくれたんですけど、最初に軽く自己紹介していただけますか、
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
はい、佐野友亮です。フロントエンジニアをしていて2024年度入社になって今ちょうど2年目になります。
本部としては、LINE公式アカウントのcmsの開発を行っていたり、社内デザインシステムの開発を行ったり。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
よろしくお願いします。玉田さんは僕より前からこのポッドキャストのホストをやっているんですけど、それでも軽く自己紹介をお願いします
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
では改めまして玉田と申します。実は佐野さんと同じチームなんですよね。ポッドキャストを収録させていただいております。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今日は社内のポットキャストが録音できるブースでオフLINEで録音してるので、いつもとちょっと雰囲気違って画面越しじゃなくて対面で話してる感じなので、ぜひ感想を聞かせてください
今回のテーマですけど、丸1か月ぐらいたったんですけど、10月にビューフェス2025年に行ってきたんですけど、そこに佐野さんが初登壇。人生の最初の登壇の経験
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
そうですね。カンファレンス初登壇2025になりましを
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
をしたので。その感想とVue Fesの全体の感想を軽く話せたらなと思います。で早速なんですけど、ビューフェスの全体的な簡素とか、ひと言でまとめるとどういう言葉がふさわしい
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
そうですね。ひと言で言うと、もうまさに祭りのなりはじない祭りっていう感じですね。たくさん人がいて楽しかったですね。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
私もビューフェスジャパンオフラインの参加が2回目で、去年も同じようなエピソードを収録したんですけれども、その時の話もそうだったんですけど、本当に佐野さんがおっしゃっていたように祭りかなと思いましたね。ひと言でしたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
長い一言って、ほんとに祭りっていうことがふさわしいと思っていて、なんか大人数もいてくれて、400人近くが多分集まったと思いますけど、その東京駅の近くの大手町プレイスっていう会場で挙げられたんですけど、あれ去年と同じ会場でしたよね。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
本当に解除も大きかったんですけど、発表のトラック3つ、4つ
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
4つですかね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
あったので、本当にいろんなセッションあったりしてて、有名なホールウェイトラックのセッションと別で、セッションの間でほかのエンジニアと会話できたりとか、そういう交換のチャンスもいっぱいあったので、本当に楽しかったなっていう感想
結構海外からのお客さんも多くて、有名なossのコントリーブーターとかいっぱい集まりましたね。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
ほんとに何かお昼食べてる時とかに有名なossコントリーブーターです。みたいな感じの紹介めちゃめちゃあったりして、こんな身近にみたいな、ほんとにグローバルというか、全然日本人だけじゃなくて、
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
僕個人的にSvelteのコミュニティーで活動してるんですけど、今回のビューフェスにパネルディスカッションがあって、そこにVueの作者のEvan YouさんとReactの元コアメンバーのDan AbramovさんとSvelteのコントリービューターのdominikgさんが来てくださったんですけど、dominikgさんが僕と同じドイツ人なので初来日だったらしくて。それで結構旅行のおすすめスポットとかいっぱい聞いてきて、多分外国のスピーカーにとっても日本に来る良いチャンスですよね。
で今回、LINEヤフー株式会社もスポンサーをやっていて、スポンサーブースも用意したんですけど、ブースのビュークイズ、何かビューの知識を試せるクイズやりましたか
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
いや、実は僕もブースで実際には解かなかったんです。あとから見たんですけど、難しかったですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
僕クイズやったんですけど結構難しくて。全然ライフサイクルとかの話が多くて、このコンポーネントだとどの順番でコンソールログが出力されるかみたいな問題があって全然駄目だったので
エンジニアを選んだことを考え直しました。そこまで
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
去年も参加していて、そのときも同じクイズ出してたんですけど、僕も全問正解は無理だったなっていう、かなり難しい問題になってましたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
でも本当に逆に難しいクイズでうれしいなって思いました。簡単すぎると何か甘やかされすぎる。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
めちゃめちゃ難しい問題出してやるぞって意気込みでパクチーも作っていたかなと思います。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
このビュークイズはブログの方にも上がっているので皆さん解けます。ちょっと文字小さいんですけど、スポンサーブースの中に解答も載っているので、皆さん是非解いてみて下さい。これそうみたいな感じですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
これ全問解いた人はもうその場で雇った方がいいですね。コンピューテッドとウォッチの違いとか難しそうですね。ブログのURLは後でノートに貼ります
じゃあ、続いて発表の簡素ですけど、佐野さんの初登壇は何のテーマに関しての登壇でしたか。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
僕は学生支援スポンサーセッションっていう、今回LINEヤフーが学生支援スポンサーっていうことで主演させて頂いた部分のこのスポンサーセッションってことで学生向けに登壇させて頂いて、題はLINE公式アカウントの技術スタッフと開発の裏側っていう題で、登壇させて頂いて、簡単に内容を紹介すると、僕が今開発しているLINE公式アカウントまわりでデザインシステムを開発しているんですけど、デザインシステムの開発についてちょっと深掘りしつつ、公式アカウントの中身を探ってみようっていう内容ですね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
本当は学生向けの発表だったんですけど、同僚3人で一番後ろに立って佐野さんを応援したので、僕も発表を見ることはできたんですけど、本当に面白かったと思います。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
ありがとうございます
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
デザインシステムの作りとかだけじゃなくて、実際にもう使われている画面も出していたのがすごい印象になってますね。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
プレゼンの中では、画面の画面を使って、Webインスペクターの中身を見ながらデザインシステムを深掘りしていくっていう内容だったので、実際に使われてる画面とその開発を
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
はい、初登壇でビューフェスっていうこともあって、初登壇がビューフェスってなかなか今回もちょうど去年は別のホールドスポンサーとしてダイヤフーは協賛していたんで
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
初登板という
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
そうですよ
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
ですけども、今回学生支援ということで、ちょうど新卒で去年も新卒デビューフェススポンサーブースで参加してみたいな流れだったので、本当に運がよくて初登壇できてうれしいなって感じ
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
佐野さん以外でもいろんな発表があったんですけど、佐野さんは多分、発表の準備とかでそうですね。ちょっと午前中は発表準備であまり見れてないので、午後の印象に残ってる発表とかってそうですね。
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
僕が一番印象に残ってるのは、ちょっとセッションというかパネルディスカッションになるんですけど、午後の3時ぐらいからあったフロンテントの未来を語るリアクトビュージェイスが見据える次の10年というパネルディスカッションがすごい印象的でおもしろかったなと。本当に満室で、席でさえ会えてなくて、本当にぎゅうぎゅう
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
一番広い会場だったんですけど、玉田さんはどうですか
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
私、いくつかいろいろと聞いていたんですけれども、そうですね。一番登壇者として私が知っていたのは、インサイドビーテスト発表の小川さんのサムネイルをすごくよく見ていたので、この人がっていう感想ですし、あとテストがそうですよね
最近、本当によく使うことが多かったので、単純に内容についてすごい参考になったところが多かったです
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうですね。何か毎日の作業で割と何か当たり前のように使ってるbテストの中身がどうなってるかとか紹介する発表だったので、個人的にはスレッドとワーカーの違いが全然分からなくて、bテストの中だと。もともとはワーカーを使っていたけど
バグが多すぎてそれをやめて。最近はノードのチャイルドプロセスを使ってオーケストレーションしてるみたいなマルチスレッティングのかなり深まった話があって、本当に面白かったなって思いました。
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
その辺りを本当に聞かないと分からないところだったかなと思います。そうですね。これは個人的に興味があったのが、ビュージェーエスで作る実験映像というセッションで、この発表をされている方も個人的に存じていてそうですね。去年のビューフェスJAPANもそうだったんですけども、そういった
インタラクション系の制作をされてる方を毎回お呼びしてるっていうのを聞いていて。今年は橋本麦さんがその方のセッションな内容だったんですけど、すごい開発者の目線では全くないんですよね。でも、こういうビュージェイスを使っているっていうのは、他の場所では聞けない
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
一番感じたセッションでこれは本当によかったなと思っています
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
そうですね、橋本麦さんのたまにXで見かけるUIへのこだわりみたいなものがすごくてこういう何て言うんですかね。こういうUIが実際に実装できたら、めっちゃユーザーとしては使いやすいだろうなみたいな思いますし、デザイナーさんっていうか、ビューフェスに今回
別のトラックでオーディオアプリケーションをWebで作るっていう音楽家の方も今回発表されていたりして、かなりエンジニアだけでない、かなりいろんな業種が集まっているカーパレスになってるなと思いましたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
結構、ビューフェスを盛り上げる回みたいなエピソードも前撮ったんですけど、そこでも話してたんですけど、結構ビューセスはエンジニア向けだけじゃなくて、Web技術を他の分野でも使ってる人が結構来てくださっているので、何か本当にエンジニアの毎日の単純作業だけじゃなくて、ちょっと変わった発表とか毎回毎回いいなと思っています。来年もぜひ行きたいなと思います
で佐野さんが先ほどおっしゃったWebオーディオのと発表。それがYogoさんっていう方、前回の盛り上げる会にもAnthonyさんとYogoさんといらっしゃった方で、個人的にはその発表すごいよかったなって思いました。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
多分広く知られているんですけど、僕は個人的にまだ1回も使ったことなかったAPIだったんですけど、オーディオソースをノードを通してフィルターとかかけて変えることができるようなAPIで、本当に未知の世界でしたね。
そこまで工夫されてるなって結構感動したところなんですけど、例えばオーディオワークレットみたいなのがあって、メインスレッドと別のスレットでオーディオの信号処理が行われているみたいなことが知って
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
だからYogoさんがその発表のスライドも全部ギットハブで公開してるので、興味のある方は是非確認して下さい。それに関しても多分ブログに書いてあるので、ショーノートを見れば分かるはずです。
ほかに印象に残ってる発表とかってありますか。ければ個人的に結構何か面白いなと思った発表なんですけど、Johnsonさんビューのコミュニティーの方で、ビューのランゲージツールを作ってる方なんですね。そのJohnsonさんの初めての英語の発表
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
だったので結構緊張されたと思いますけど、内容がすごく面白くて。ビューをエディターで使うとそこビュースリーになってからいろいろ変わってきたんですけど、最初はVeturっていうランゲージサーバーだったんですけど、
最近になって、フレームワークアグノスティックな、どのフレームワークでも動くランゲージサーバーを作っていて、ランゲージサーバーの基盤ですかね。Volarっていうツールなんですけど、何かどうやって今のVolarのアキテクチャーとかにたどりついたとかの内容が
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
すごく面白くて、毎日の開発で当たり前のように作ってるツールなんですけど、実装自体が死ぬほど複雑だなって初めて理解して面白かったです
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
ボーラーも結構家の開発者なら全員使ってるんじゃないかってぐらい有名なエステンションですけど、見たかったです
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
で、フレームワークアクノスティックなので、何か最近ちょっと話題になってる新しいフレームワークのripple.jsがあるんですけど、例えばそのフレームワークが新しいシンタックスを考えてるのに、その基盤を使ってすごい精度のよいランゲージサーバーを短時間で作ることができました。
あと、他に聞いた発表なんですけど、今回はナイトニントークのトラックもあって。そこでssssotaさん、ちょうど
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
僕は見ました
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ZOZOTOWNのテクリードをやっている方なんですけど、ジャーバースキフトの環境でどうやってラストで作ったツールを動かすかみたいな発表はあったんですけど、
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
最近ラストとか結構ノWeb会話でかなり有名というか、広く使われるんですして、高速かつみたいなガーセンブリーだったりっていうのが登場して、かなり使われるようになってきたかなって思うんですけど、確かに何かあれ、ラストな環境作ったことないよなみたいなものを考えたりして、そうですね。すごい確かに考えてみたら、どうやって動いてるんだろうみたいなところもあって、そうですか
俺、ラストな環境作ったことないよなみたいな
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
具を深めるためにすぐ聞いてよかったので面白かったですね
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
私も去年もすごい思った感想なんですけど、リューフェスJAPANってビューだけじゃない。いろいろな内容も取り上げてるんですけども。その中だって、もうツールチェーンのトピックってすごいよくて、やっぱりoxcとかそういったRust製のツールの発表っていうのも含めて、
Viteもそうですし、そういったところも含めてっていう内容になってるので、さっきその話したエンジニア以外の内容も多いとは言いつつも、こういうがっつりとツールチェインRustとかエンジニアリングのこれすいません話聞いてないので、内容全然違ってたら申し訳ないんですけども、そういう内容、話されてるっていうところもすごい面白いですよね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
本当に僕もそう思っていて、ちょっとアートに近い非技術的な話から、それも技術を使って作っているので、すごい技術に深いお詳しい方が登壇してるんですけど、発表内容としてはそこまで技術的な話じゃないですか
じゃない発表もあれば、すごいマニアックなラストのメモリーを直接いじるとか、そういう発表もあるので、
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
本当にそれこそビューフェスだけど、発表する登壇者の方々はリアクトベース界の感謝だったり、それこそチームの開発者だったりっていう、かなりujsだけでもなく、ほかのフロントエンドフレームワークだったり、フロントドライブラリーのメインのホントにグーターな方々もそれぞれ発表していて、すごい面白いなって思いますね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
きましたけど、今回はもう隠れなくても普通にアスペルトの人として行けたのでそうですね。パネルディスカ所でもリアクトvsビューブリススベルトみたいな話してましたけど、確かに
先ほど佐野さんが話していたパネルディスカッションについて、もうちょっと深く話せたらなって思ったんですけど、内容としては先ほど佐野さんもおっしゃってたんですけど、フロントエンド開発の未来っていう内容だったんですけど、かなりAIの話になりましたね。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
そうですね。7割、8割ぐらいはもうAIについて
個人的に面白いって思ったのが、ビューの作者のエヴァンさんが割とAIに関しての楽観的な考え方を持っていたことに対して、スペルトのドミニックさんが結構AIアンチみたいな発言をしてたのが、そうやって
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
そうでしたね
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
意見が違うと、やっぱりパネルディスカッション面白くなるので良かったなと思います
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
やっぱり個人的には最近のAIとフロントエンドについては、個人的にはスドウィニックさんがおっしゃっていた。実際エヴァンさんとかも言ってたんですけど、実際AI使ってフロントエンドの開発をしても、自分の生成したコードが生成した人の技術力を超えることはあんまり多くはないみたいな、基本的に自分のフロントエンドの技術者としての力が、そのまま生成されたコードにも依存するよ、みたいなことを言っていたかなと思うんですけど、確かになってもらって、フロントエンド開発する
中でたまにAIは使うんですけども、ちゃんと自分がリビューできないと、運用していく中でだんだん厳しくなってくるみたいな部分もあって。結構そういう全部AIに任せればいいんじゃないみたいな部分は結構難しいなって最近思ってますね
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
私も結構面白かったのはスタンスもそうですし、あと正直にそこのAIのツールにこの機能については実はそんなに詳しくないみたいなのが話していてすごい。必ずしもossの著名なコントリデーターであっても、AIについて何でも知ってるわけではないっていうのは、すごい人間味があるところだとは思いますし、かといって絶対私たちよりもハードスキルっていうのは断然上なはずですし、そこから見た視点っていうのも面白い
NOTE Speaker: YusukeSano
まさにAIが生成するコードを書いてる人たち。AIが生成するためのコードを書いてるので、確かにその人たちがAI使っても何が作れるんだろうみたいな。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
確かにAIが参照にして学習するコードを書いてる人たちですね。まさに個人的に結構印象に残ってる発言ですけど、Googleのエンジニアなんで絶対うそだと思いますから。そこまで強くないから、AIで大事になってくるスキルはどっちかというと、そういうアルゴリズム系のザエンジニアみたいなハードスキルじゃないですか
マネージメント的なソフトスキルがどんどん大事になってくるんじゃないかなっていうことを言ってたんですけど、確かにソフトスキルがより大事になってきそうだなって思って。すごい感動しましたね。AIは結構いい精度のアルクリズム
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
で、個人的にもそこまでアルゴリズムの力がないと自分で思ってるんですけど、何かそういうマネージメントみたいなスキルだったらまだできそうって思ってて。個人的に結構うれしかったです
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
逆にそれは個人的にどうなんだろうって思う時もあってすごい。ほんとにもうおっしゃっていたように、人と対話するみたいな扱いで話していたのはほんとに面白かったですね。
かのように話すけども、そういう意見が同じ。その辺りは本当に同じ意見だと思ったので面白かったです
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
という訳で、今回はビューフェス2025年について話してきました。LINEヤフーのフロントエンドコミュニティーUITでは、このようなフロントエンドにかかわる議論や意見交換を日々行なっています。過去のエピソードでは社内勉強会などから発生したものも
また、このポットキャストに関するご意見、ご感想があれば、UITサイドについてつぶやいていただけたらスタッフにて確認します。玉田さん、佐野さん、ありがとうございました
NOTE Speaker: spring_raining
ありがとうございました